de perfil futurista así fue el último
desfile del diseñador pierre cardin casi
un año después la leyenda de la moda
francesa murió a los 98 años en un
hospital de parís nacido en el seno de
una familia humilde de origen italiano
kayden consiguió coronarse en lo más
alto de la moda francesa se inició como
aprendiz de sastre a los 17 años y al
mudarse a la ciudad de luz empezó a
trabajar con grandes firmas como
christian dior
traté de hacerlo distinto a los demás
para hacer yo mismo si le gustaba o no a
la gente no era la cuestión tenemos que
ser diferentes para ser reconocidos sin
mencionar el nombre este es un jardín
este es otro sencillo pronto se ganó el
nombre de innovador ya que sus diseños
eran visionarios a la vez que accesibles
para todos los bolsillos
el francés creó su imperio a base de las
necesidades de las mujeres de los 60 que
se querían incorporar al mercado laboral
y sólo podían permitirse prendas low
cost
llegó a su público con vestidos
futurísticos y aptos para uno desea
espacial una evolución creo que la moda
no puede ser estable hay un estilo que
puede gustar o no a la gente pero debe
cambiar
yo digo presente pasado y futuro que
significa que el futuro no está aquí
pero que se convertirá en el pasado como
modista con gran proyección
internacional llegó a explorar los
mercados de japón rusia y china- bajo la
máxima de la originalidad también
recibió grandes reconocimientos como el
premio del consejo de diseñadores de
américa dejando una huella eterna en el
mundo de la moda